Good morning, Hank!
It is Tuesday, November 8th, 2016.
It’s Pizzamas!
The most magical time of the year!
So, every year during Pizzamas, we make videos
on vlogbrothers every weekday for two weeks.
Unfortunately, Hank, you scheduled the arrival
of your child poorly and you’re on paternity leave.
What’s that?
Oh, apparently you can’t schedule the arrival
of a child.
But Pizzamas is full of magic, and so as part
of that, you managed to somehow upload a video
during your paternity leave.
Not just a video, by the way, but a video
with you dancing in it.
That’s my favorite kind of vlogbrothers
video.
Did you know that Hank Green was named Winter
Park High School’s Best Dancer in 1998?
It’s true.
Wait, what just happened to my face?
It’s a Pizzamas miracle!
My mustache is back!
Also, in totally predictable news, I have
cut myself shaving.
By the way, I have been growing a beard for
two months for this joke, so I hope you enjoy
how ridiculous I look.
So the Pizza John story is so complicated
that I can’t even really bring myself to
explain it to new nerdfighters, but Hank made
a video a while back with the highlights.
But basically, every year there’s a bunch
of limited edition Pizza John merch, like
this year there’s this La Croix Pizza John.
There’s also this Pizza John hoodie.
Hank reached out to a bunch of his favorite
T-shirt designers, and many of them designed
awesome Pizza John shirts.
You can find them all at dftba.com.
Also, all the Pizza John stuff is only available
during Pizzamas, and then it will disappear forever.
Ugh, God, I just look so bad with this mustache.
I look like a 39-year-old man impersonating
a nine-year-old impersonating a police officer.
It’s even worse than the one from last year,
but you never know what gifts Pizzamas is gonna bring.
Wait a second, hold up, back up the tape for
a second.
Did I just say, “It is Tuesday, November
8th, 2016”?
November 8th, why is that date important?
Oh right, it’s because the Pizza John PJs
are being made right here in Indianapolis
on November 8th.
I actually prefer to call them the PJ PJs.
Alright, I gotta head over to the pajama factory.
And for better or worse, I’m taking my mustache
with me.
Quick story: I didn’t get this on video
because I’m a bad vlogger who’s terrified
of pulling out his camera in public places
except for airports, but I just got a cup
of coffee, and after I ordered, the woman
behind the counter said, “I mustache you
if you would like room for cream,” and I
just wanna say for the record, well played.
Alright, Hank, I’ve arrived at Krazy Klothes!
Time to go see my pajamas!
I’m John, nice to meet you.
Hi, John, nice to meet you.
So first Debby lays out the fabric, then it
goes through this amazing machine, where it
is imprinted with my mustachioed face.
Now, there are some parts of the process that
are automated, but every pair of Pizza John
pajamas is cut and sewn by hand right here
in Indianapolis.
And when they’re all done, they look like
this.
I think that’s all I had scheduled for November
8th.
Just kidding, I have to go vote.
I already texted myself my sample ballot.
By the way, on my phone, I’ve got this great
Pizza John popsocket.
It’s so useful! Never not self-promoing.
Quick side note: If you’re an American and
you can vote, listen to the man with the mustache.
Look up your polling place in the dooblydoo.
If you need a refresher on anything you might
need to bring to the polls, go to youtube.com/howtovoteineverystate
and look up your state.
And go vote!
You can do this!
I’m about to do it with a mustache, wearing
a portrait of myself with a mustache.
Okay, I’m on my way into my polling place.
And now I have voted.
Again, if you need voting resources, you can
find some in the dooblydoo below.
Happy Pizzamas, and happy Election Day!
I’m not gonna lie, I’m a little bit nervous,
but I’m just—I’m just trying to keep my cool.
Who am I kidding, I’m a lot bit nervous.
Hank, I will not see you tomorrow, but I’ll
see somebody on vlogbrothers.
Vote!